It's great to welcome to the program today,
Kade Crockford, who's the director of the
technology for Liberty program at [inaudible],
the ACLU of Massachusetts. Uh, Kate, great
to have you on. I appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
So I want to talk about biometric surveillance,
facial recognition, and how uh, law enforcement,
um, may or can use these technologies. But
first, you know, recently on the program,
I had someone call in and talk about, Hey
David hasn't what we mean by a right to privacy
been drastically altered by the technologies
that exist today in the sense that a hundred
years ago in public legally you might have
had a very similar, uh, set of rights and
laws as you have today. But in practice, a
lot of the technologies that exist today and
didn't a hundred years ago have changed what
it means to be anonymous or to be in private
or in public. What should our understanding
of this be under the law? But then also kind
of a more colloquial understanding.
That's a great question. Um, people need to
remember that in a democracy in our societies
is sensibly a democracy. We, the people are
in charge, not, uh, corporations or government
agencies like the FBI. Um, so we have the
power, at least the heretically to determine
how new technologies ought to impact our right
to privacy, to anonymity, even in public space.
So I just want to remind folks that the constitution,
the way that it's interpreted by the courts
is merely a floor. It is not a ceiling. So
in other words, we could certainly, if we
wanted to pass laws, um, prohibiting corporations
from selling our cell site location information,
that's the information revealing where we've
been, where we've traveled with our cell phones
in the past. Um, we could do that. It just
requires a political will. We certainly could
prohibit or severely restrict the government
from using technologies like facial recognition
and public space. That's merely a political
problem. It's not a technological problem.
So certainly technology has changed. Um, the
degree to which both corporations and governments
can create really, um, comprehensive records
of our movements, our activities, our associations,
our interests. Um, but that's not necessarily,
uh, inevitable. It is merely because we have
not taken the necessary political steps to
ensure that our technology, um, does not outpace
the law with respect to our privacy protections.
And when we start to look at the ways in which
law enforcement use or utilize some of these
technologies. We've talked about everything
from the S I believe they're called sting
Ray, a cell tower of sort of replicators.
I may be lacking the exact right vocabulary,
but the idea that the police can have a device
that your cell phone will believe is just
another cell tower and connect to it. And
by virtue of that, you are passing a lot of
information on to law enforcement, biometric
surveillance, facial recognition software.
We're gonna get into some of these specifics
and where they're being used. But what is
the position of the ACL? Uhhh, generally speaking
about law enforcement's ability to use these
different technologies when a warrant does
not exist for the specific surveillance of
an individual.
So just as a general matter, um, the fourth
amendment provides for our right to privacy
and says essentially that unless you're involved
in criminal activity and the government can
show evidence of that which is called probable
cause to a judge and get a warrant, they shouldn't
be able to invade your privacy. Now, as we
kind of discussed before there an active debate
about what privacy means in the 21st century.
So just as an example, a recent Supreme court
case, um, that was decided in the summer of
2018 last summer called carpenter versus United
States is the most important privacy ruling.
We've seen that the Supreme court in a long
time and that case is particularly important
because it, um, disagreed with one enforcement's
interpretation of the fourth amendment, which
essentially was that when you go out in public,
you have no right to privacy. So the court
held in a very important ruling in the carpenter
ruling in a decision written by chief justice
Roberts that in fact technology has substantially
changed the balance of power between the government
and the people.
Now, you know, in a free society, in a democracy,
the government ought to know almost nothing
about the general population unless we've
affirmatively disclosed information to the
government to receive benefits or something
like that. And we should know almost everything
about what the government is doing, new surveillance
technologies. And unfortunately the post nine
11 hysteria around terrorism has really flipped
that balance. So now the government, and this
is true of even local and state police officers
all the way up to the level of the federal
government at the FBI and the da, et cetera,
they can know almost everything about us often
without a warrant. And we know very little
about what they're doing because their operations
are shrouded in secrecy. So the carpenter
ruling is really important because it sticks
a very clear, uh, claim rather, uh, draws
a line in the sand for 21st century forms
of service surveillance by essentially saying
it is vastly different for one enforcement
to use technology like cell phone tracking.
Um, you know, technologies like cell cell
site location information, information that
is maintained on hundreds of millions of people
across the United States that is qualitatively
and quantitatively different from law enforcement
following one person around to see where they're
going. And this is an important concept that
we call friction, right? Um, there are only
so many police officers in the U S I think
there are too many. There are about a million.
Um, but there are over 300 million people
in this country. Right. And so it would be
physically impossible for law enforcement
to follow each one of us around. Um, noting
our every movement, every day of our lives.
Cell phone technology makes it possible not
only for law enforcement to see where we are
in the present moment and on a mass scale,
but also to do something that was previously
impossible, which is to find out where we
were three weeks ago, three months ago, six
months ago before we were even under a criminal
investigation or suspected of a crime.
And so chief justice Roberts says that because
the technology facilitates, um, a new form
of mass tracking that is not possible without
the technology, the government is required
to get a warrant, even if they're merely tracking
our public movements, even if they're not
tracking our private movements in our home,
even if they're just tracking where we go
on public streets. Because previous to the
existence of this technology, um, that type
of surveillance was actually not even feasible.
Um, so yes, master valence is distinct from
individualized, targeted surveillance that
law enforcement is engaged in because they
believe that someone is actually engaged in
a crime. New technologies, license plate readers,
face surveillance technology, certainly cell
phone tracking, give the government the power
to very cheaply conduct surveillance of hundreds
of millions of people's movements and activities.
And again, not just in the present moment,
but actually reversing back in time to see
what we've been doing, uh, days, weeks, or
months before.
So let's now dig in a little bit to the specifics
of how some of these technologies are being
implemented of different types of biometric
surveillance and facial recognition. Where
is it currently being used?
So, um, there's a lot we don't know, unfortunately,
especially about what the federal government
is doing with face surveillance technology,
um, by remote biometric, uh, tracking technologies
we view as distinct from the traditional forms
of biometric surveillance that the government
has conducted, including fingerprints and
DNA and the reason that, um, Iris scanning
gate scanning. So that's the way that you
walk [inaudible] is also, uh, biometric just
was just means something that's unique to
each individual. Um, of course our faces,
there's even some science that says art. The
shape of our ears is a biometric. So these
new forms of biometrics that the FBI has been
experimenting with for years now and that
state and local law enforcement are beginning
to use to track and identify people. Those
are distinct from fingerprints and DNA for
one simple reason. And we need to think of
them as a class, as uniquely dangerous.
For this reason, it is necessary. Again, this
is back to the concept of friction. If one
enforcement wants to get my fingerprints or
my DNA, they actually have to send someone
physically to follow me to pick up my coffee
cup or my cigarette. But when I've thrown
it down the ground or in the trash, um, to
test that material, that physical material,
it is not possible yet. Maybe it will be someday,
but it's not possible yet to pluck someone's
DNA from a camera that is, um, you know, coming
from a satellite in space, it is easy, trivial
actually, and it's going to become even easier
for governments and corporations to collect
and store our biometrics like our IRS, our
face, our ears, the way that we walk our gate
remotely and therefore end mass. Again, this
concept of friction is really important. You
can't have 1 million police officers collecting
300 million people's DNA.
It's simply impractical. You can very easily
in the kind of China style surveillance system
that we're seeing in certain regions of that
country, set up camera networks that facilitate
the mass tracking of people through their,
um, biometrics that are, that are, um, detectable
remotely. So how is this happening? Again,
we're not sure what's going on at the federal
level. The FBI is very secretive. Congress
has asked a lot of questions that have gone
on the answer to the of the FBI. We aimed
to find out, we filed a public records request,
um, in January with, uh, against the FBI and
the drug enforcement administration asking
them for information about how they use these
technologies or particularly concerned about
in the absence of any regulation, the FBI
using these technologies to track and monitor
dissonance at protests and places like standing
rock, um, you know, climate, racial justice,
anti-war, anti Trump types of, um, uh, activists.
And we do know, however, that the FBI has
access to 640 million images of adults in
the United States. So that's more obviously
than every adult in the country. So essentially
every single person with a state identification
card, uh, every person who's been arrested
is, uh, in a database that's accessible to
the FBI for facial surveillance purposes.
Um, that's pretty terrifying and Congress
has thus far, I've done nothing to stop it.
We also know that at the local level, like
for example, here in Massachusetts, the driver's
license state ID database maintained by the
registry of motor vehicles is basically a
perpetual lineup for law enforcement, face
surveillance searches. So we know that since
2006, um, state and local and federal law
enforcement have been using that database,
uh, to conduct maybe fishing expeditions,
um, pulling images from Facebook when they
want to identify someone and running it against
the RMBS database, using facial recognition
technology to try to identify people, um,
that's been happening without any judicial
oversight with no legislative authorization,
uh, no probable cause or even reasonable suspicion
is required, um, by police. They don't have
to demonstrate that anybody's involved in
a crime before they can perform one of these
searches. And so we're very concerned that
in the absence of any oversight or accountability,
uh, at the state level, these systems are
being abused and misused currently.
Yeah, I mean, my, you know, anytime when I'm
hearing about any policy and someone presents
a very black and white view, my instinct is
to be skeptical of that because like with
most things, there are sort of things on both
side of the ledger. So if we step back for
a moment from the legality, I could imagine
that on the one hand, this is technology that
can be used to, uh, not only invade people's
privacy in cases when they actually haven't
done anything wrong, but also misidentify
people that might disproportionately, uh,
be inaccurate with people from certain, uh,
races, gender. I mean, who knows, right? There's
all sorts of, of things on the bad side of
the ledger. On the other hand, there are probably
some ways in which this technology can lead
to speedier resolution of a crime or more
quickly finding a potential, uh, of violent
person or whatever is, it's all hypothetical.
But then we get to what you're talking about,
which is this seems to go beyond some of the
basic tenants of how law enforcement is supposed
to operate based on the rules that have been
established with regard to warrants and probable
cause and how investigations have to be done.
And that's where I feel like the concern goes
beyond merely evaluating whether the ends
are worthwhile.
Yeah. I mean, they're, in my view, there are
three distinct ways that this technology can
be used. One is to, as I said before, perform
an identification of someone. So say there's
a dead person, right? Um, law enforcement
find somebody dead and it dead in a ditch.
They don't know who this person is. They're
not carrying any identification. They run
the fingerprints. The person's never been
arrested. They're not, you know, identifiable
that way. Facial recognition could be a valuable
tool in that case, right? You take a picture
of the person's face, you run it against a
database, like the registry of motor vehicles
to try to find out who is this dead body.
Um, there's a second way that the technology
can be used, which is vastly different, which
is to, uh, supercharge effectively all of
the surveillance camera networks that exist
in our cities and towns across the United
States with a automation technology that makes
it possible.
You know, in the future, the technology is
not really Mariette, it doesn't quite work,
but it will get better. And in the future,
the technology may enable government agencies
to type in your name. David Parkman hit enter
and then automatically the software will stitch
together a video showing every single place
you've been over the past five, 10 years,
however long the video is stored, who you
are with what you were doing, and prepare
a nice little report. Uh, David Parkman was
seen outside the cannabis shop on this date.
He was seen outside the planned Parenthood
on this date. He was seen at a mosque on this
date. He was seen at a protest on this date.
He was seen with a whistleblower on this date,
right? So that type of surveillance is this
stuff that we're actually the most concerned
about and we think has no place in a democratic
society that is actually something that should
just be banned permanently.
We should never allow government agencies
to create architectures that are [inaudible]
of surveillance that facilitate that kind
of mass tracking of people in public space.
It has no place in a free society. There's
a third way, which is also very scary, which
is a facial analysis technology. So this is
technology that purports to be able to discern
whether someone is happy or sad or anxious
or stressed by evaluating their face. Now
a lot of it's junk science. A really important,
um, research paper was published by scholars
at Northeastern university, including Dr.
Lisa Barrett, who's a world renowned psychologist.
She reviewed over 2000 papers in this area
and found essentially that, uh, due to cultural
differences, you know, people with autism,
et cetera, um, people depending on the moods
that they're in in different contexts, it
is actually not possible to discern how someone
is feeling by evaluating the physical characteristics
of their face.
So we are very concerned that law enforcement,
other government agencies will start to adopt
technologies that purport to be able to tell
police officers potentially in a very, um,
high stress, dangerous situation. Whether
the person that they're looking at is stressed,
has a criminal record and, um, you know, may
be armed and dangerous. And if T if the technology
gets stuff wrong in that kind of context,
which we assume it will because technology
frequently gets things wrong. Um, that could
mean the difference between life and death
for a human being walking on the streets of
a, of an American city. And so we want to
make sure, again that those types of facial
analysis tools that are already in relatively
widespread use in the commercial sector. So
for example, in remote job interviews, they're,
they're doing these, um, over, they're using
these, these technologies over technologies
like Skype.
Um, when you're applying for a job at a, at
a large corporation, we want to make sure
that government agencies are not using those
technologies to evaluate, for example, in
the interrogation room whether someone's telling
the truth or not when they're talking to the
police. So there are two categories of the
technology that we actually think should never
be adopted and a free society. The other,
the right, like we have an image of someone's
face and we want to identify this person.
I think that, for example, with dead people,
um, potentially with all simers patients and
potentially in very, very, you know, a specific
criminal investigations where there's a really
high, uh, risk to the public. Like for example,
in a murder investigation, um, with the appropriate
level of judicial oversight and transparency
and you know, rigorous auditing and public
oversight that that type of surveillance may
have a place in the 21st century. But there
are some forums again that really just shouldn't.
Um, and we have the power again in a democracy
to draw that line and say, you know what,
Amazon and Jeff Bezos have a certain idea
of what the future will look like. We have
a different one and we're going to make sure
that our is a wins out.
We've been speaking with Kade Crockford who's
the director of the technology for Liberty
program at the HCLU of Massachusetts. Kate,
thanks so much for talking to us about this
today. I appreciate it. Thanks a lot.